I am in the coffee room where element 109,
meitnerium was
named. In here, imagine it: 20 people sitting
round arguing
“What are we going to call this new element?”
Writing the
names on the blackboard…they rubbed it off!
But there, they
had the whole choice of what the elements
were called.
Like many others of these very heavy elements,
meitnerium
was made by taking a nucleus of a heavy element
and
banging into it a lighter element. In the
case of this one you
have lead with atomic number 82 and bang into
it cobalt, or
alternatively you can have bismuth which has
atomic number
83 and bang in iron which has atomic number
one less than
cobalt so you have 2 different ways of making
the same
element.
I was just told by Sigurd Hofmann, one of
the discoverers,
they chose the name, mietnerium because Lisa
Mietner who
was the co-discoverer of fission of atoms
never got the Nobel
Prize, her collaborator Otto Hahn got the
Nobel Prize she
didn’t. Now she has got an element named
after her, and he
hasn’t, so her name will live longer than
his. I think it would
be really exciting to choose the name of an
element.
Well Professor, you are sitting next to a
man who does get to
name elements, this is your one chance to
tell him what you
think he should call any future elements that
he might get to
have a say in, let’s see what you are going
to suggest to him.
I think, I still think that it would be nice
to honour Max Planck
and I also think that Planckium is a nice
name it rolls off the
tongue.
What do you think? Planckium, will you bear
that one in mind
for us next time you have to name an element?
I think now, Planckium, we can write in bold
letters because
he already was on our list.
Ok there you go! Planckium might be in the
running next
time, are you happy?
Yes, thankyou.
Ok.
Lisa Mietner was the first woman ever to get
a PhD , a
doctorate in physics, in Austria and then
she moved to Berlin.
During the First World War she worked on a
mobile x-ray unit
for x-raying wounded soldiers and then she
worked in Berlin
with Max Planck. And there is a very nice
story that
Rutherford sent radioactive samples to them
by post from
Cambridge and she could tell when a parcel
was coming to
her from Cambridge before looking at it, while
the postman
was still holding it, because her Geiger-counter
started
detecting radioactivity coming out of the
parcel. People were
not quite so careful when they sent radioactive
samples in
those days as they are now.